hi
everyone um this is priyana tarajan the
current director of the frankie program
in science and the humanities at yale
i'm absolutely
delighted to invite you all to
our convening and distinguished speaker
series
today and the title of the talk today is
a better planet
40 big ideas for a sustainable future
but before i tell you about our
distinguished guests
let me start by thanking our benefactors
richard and barbara frankie for their
generosity in funding this program
that enables all the exciting activities
that we are able to do
and i'm really grateful that you know we
have our activities are such up in such
a format that
in this moment of pandemic disarray we
are
able to continue and i i'm very sorry
that we are not able to offer the
wonderful receptions in-person
receptions the
food and drink that go with this the um
the celebratory atmosphere but however
um we are going to make do with
intellectual excitement and
so first i uh need to uh
all of you who are assembled that we are
recording this event
and that all participants must therefore
mute their videos
because then we would have to get
individual permissions and so on so
kindly mute your videos
wish you could submit talks through the
chat feature this is what this is the
process we followed
previously and tai will
help us moderate this and thank you so
much tai for doing that
so um our speaker today i am
thrilled to introduce one of our own
distinguished faculty
members professor dan este dan este is
the hill house professor
at yale university with primary
appointments
at yale's environmental and law schools
and a secondary
appointment at the yale school of
management he currently serves as the
director of the yale center for
environmental law and policy
co-director of the yale initiative on
sustainable finance
current research and writing offer
cutting-edge thinking
about climate change sustainable
investing
innovation and the energy environment in
the energy environment context
and of course matters of corporate
sustainability and
brand new approaches radical new
approaches to environmental protection
he is a pioneer pioneering thinker in
helping us
reshape how we should think about
climate change and how to alleviate it
he is the author and editor or editor of
12 books and dozens of articles on
environmental protection regulatory
reform energy policy and sustainability
metrics
and their connections to corporate
strategy competitiveness so very much
rooted in the policy and the real world
he is he had a prize winning he's had
many prize-winning books uh his
latest book a 2019 book in which he has
edited a wonderful set of essays and i
would like to
highly recommend that i thoroughly
enjoyed reading it
and dan just mentioned that it's just
come out in paperback so i really urge
you all
to buy it and read it so this book was
just
awarded the financial ft book of the
year award and his previous prize
winning volume was green to gold
how smart companies use environmental
strategy to innovate creative create
value and build competitive advantage
and this has recently been named one of
the top green business books of the past
decade and he has had many interesting
articles i would like to point
one out that i think uh was particularly
impactful for me
red lights to green lights from 20th
century environmental regulation to 21st
century
sustainability so i wanted to say a
little bit about
his career trajectory only because of
how distinguished it is and how
varied it is and it gives you a sense of
someone who
really crosses disciplinary boundaries
that is a hallmark
of what we celebrate at the frankie
program from 2011 to 2014
uh professor st served as commissioner
of connecticut's department of energy
and environmental protection
where he earned a reputation for fresh
thinking and practical results
his policy innovations he launched many
policy innovations
uh include the launch of connecticut's
first in the nation green bank to
promote
clean energy using limited public
funding to leverage
private capital and the lean
restructuring of all of connecticut's
environmental permitting programs
to make the state's regulatory framework
lighter faster and more efficient
as well as effective prior to taking up
his professorship at yale in 1994 he
served in a variety of senior positions
at the u.s epa where he helped manage
the agency's regulatory program so you
can see
that he has had enormous impact both in
the policy realm
uh with action as well as intellectual
heft with his um
ideas he's also worked as a senior
fellow at the peterson institute for
international economics in washington dc
where he did some breakthrough work on
links between trade and environmental
issues
and the broader challenges of global
globalization
so before we um head into today's talk i
just wanted to remind you of two
upcoming events the next two
monthly talks just want to briefly
advertise them
the talk for um november is going to be
in the mapping is knowing series
and for that uh the speaker for that uh
if we managed to snag
the famous science fiction writer
and thinker of the anthropocene kim
stanley robinson
and our december edition of the mapping
as knowing talk is going to be given by
frank
snowden who has worked on epidemics
and so anyway without further ado dan
we are delighted to have you here and
look forward to hearing from you
thank you so much for accepting our
invitation bria thank you so very much
for
having me um and uh special thanks to ty
camp who organized uh today's program
and uh to barbara frankie who makes this
all possible so
i'm i'm grateful and really thank you to
all of you who are taking time out of
your busy
day to be part of this program today i'm
going to present for a bit but very much
hope to move to a conversation and a
back and forth dialogue
um in the not too far future um
so let me uh start by saying that it's
just a great pleasure to have a chance
to talk about this better planet book
uh especially in the week that it comes
out in paperback
it's uh i i hadn't planned it this way
but it's great timing
and for those who are interested there
is in the chat
um a a brochure with a discount coupon
so if anyone finds themselves motivated
to go out and buy the book
yale university press will make it uh
worth your while with the coupon
so they're in fact i think two of the
brochures of the book one of them has a
coupon attached
now i want to start by saying that it's
actually
a incredibly interesting moment and one
might even say a critical moment
for the discussion that i want to have
about a sustainable future
including climate change but also
addressing a broader set of issues
and i say that not just because
we're sitting here on the east coast at
least some of us
while the west coast is on fire uh
california has been burning
um but we've also seen hurricanes pile
off one on top of another
into the gulf coast both of these
elements
of uh climatic danger are i think
signals not necessarily of any specific
climate change we can link up in a very
tight causal
connection but of the kind of world that
climate scientists tell us we should
anticipate
in the years ahead and i do think the
the threat of climate change
and the broader challenge to
sustainability is become more and more
evident
it's become a question uh in our
political
dialogue certainly in the election
campaign these issues are playing a much
more prominent role
but i really actually want to say that
what's special about the moment from my
point of view
is that we are about to shift gears as a
nation uh next month we shift maybe not
on the day after the election but by the
end of november i'm hopeful
that we shift from all politics all the
time
to questions of policy and that's where
this book
really has its place uh it is as you
heard uh
subtitled 40 big ideas for a sustainable
future
it is a a volume that uh i edited but
represents uh 56 different authors in
these 40 essays
offering up a range of perspectives from
a range of political starting points
and a range of underlying disciplines
including some folks who are
practitioners and not academics
but all offer interesting perspectives
on
critical issues and thoughtful carefully
constructed
analytically rigorous pathways forward
and that's what i'm actually very
excited to
dig into a bit today uh the book is by
the way
from yale university press a great
partnership with the long
time editor there who's done science and
environment gene thompson black
so really just a huge pleasure to have
been able to work with her
and to bring this volume to publication
in record time and it grows out of
an effort that the environment school by
the way those who have been following
you for a long time may not have
kept up with the fact that the yale
school of forestry and environmental
studies has rebranded itself as of a
couple of months ago
as the yale school of the environment
and the new dean of a few years ago indy
burke
launched the school on an effort to
rethink its direction and strategic plan
and one of the things that emerged was a
commitment to be more of a convening
platform
to bring people together to talk about
sustainability and how to get to a
sustainable future
and this book really grows out of that
broader dialogue the yale environmental
dialogue as we call it
organized by um uh dean indy burke and
now kind of a core part of the school's
program
and uh the book itself offers a a
range of concepts and principles for
thinking about environmental challenges
and related clean energy questions land
use issues natural resource management
so the full
spectrum of sustainability issues uh it
offers frameworks it looks at
technologies it looks at
pathways and strategies so it really is
um
an interesting compilation of ideas
by the way uh it represents a number of
offer off
authors from within the school of the
environment others from across the yale
campus more broadly
some number of alums as well and uh
three essays are written by students uh
who
were able to win the chance to be in the
book based on a very competitive process
so let me offer you um some thoughts um
and i want to start by saying um that
the idea of my chapter
is that we need to imagine
a different way of thinking about the
environment in the 21st century
from what we did in the 20th century so
that's the core hypothesis
i'm introducing that what we did in the
past particularly
as we launched the modern era of
environmental protection in the united
states
in the 1970s and in the 1980s worked
at the time served the purpose of that
era but is not serving us so well today
and that what we really need is a fresh
approach a new approach
that advances our strategy and gives us
a a more clear path to a sustainable
future
my essay in the book is called red
lights to green lights
toward an incentive oriented
sustainability strategy
and a greater focus on incentives on how
we change behavior
change company behavior particularly the
big polluting industry behavior
but how we change individual choices in
behavior
is really i think a fundamental issue
and of real
concern and needs to be a focus in
environmental policy
so that's my own essay but i'm also
building on a need for
better incentives to engage people in
delivering the results we need
more use of information and information
technology
which of course wasn't available in the
same way in the 20th century
when our modern efforts in environmental
protection were launched
i also having spent a lot of time trying
to understand what's worked and what
hasn't over the last 50 years
believe that we need to put much more
focus on investment
how we flow money to solve environmental
problems and put us toward a sustainable
future
i think we under attended to that
problem in the 1970s 80s
somehow there was an idea that if the
law was framed the money would follow
turned out not to be true um i also
think there is a need to
focus on integration on a more systems
oriented approach we might call it a
more ecological approach
to these problems and i'm going to dig
in on
all of this uh over the course of the
next 20 minutes or so
as i lay out my argument for why we need
a 21st century approach to environmental
protection
and how this better planet book sketches
uh not only in my essay but in all the
essays
some of the elements of what that might
look like
so first of all i want to be clear that
i'm not saying that the 20th century
strategy
of environmental protection was a
failure quite to the contrary
we have better quality air now much
better quality
rivers for those who pick up the book
you'll see that the introductory chapter
i note that i grew up along the nagaduck
river in northwestern connecticut
and that river used to flow orange and
purple depending on the colors of the
uniroyal factory
that was dumping its waste into the
river the river is much cleaner today
it's swimmable there's fish in it so we
have made
huge progress as a society but i do
think they're important questions about
how we continue to make progress and
address the residual problems
that continue to plague us and that's um
where my argument
focuses on the need for innovation my
belief is we've gotten a good distance
with a certain set of strategies
but to go where we need to go over the
coming years we need new ideas new
approaches
new technologies to be brought into the
sustainability world
and my basic claim
is that the 20th century approach to
environmental protection
was largely around telling people
particularly the business world what
not to do so putting up a red light a
stop sign saying don't do that
don't pollute can't go there and uh that
sort of red light strategy did change
behavior in some regards
but it was not very good at getting
business
to become solutions providers so we
don't have
a transformed energy foundation for our
society compared to what we thought we
might have
in the way of transformation over the
past 50 years
so i want to argue that we should have
just as we have at any intersection
not just red lights that tell people
when to stop but green lights that tell
people when to go
we need the same framework of green
lights as a complement to red lights
in environmental regulation and what i
mean really is that we need incentives
we need to
get people who have the capacity to
solve problems
to step up to those issues to become
solutions providers and i think
my argument is that we need to really
structure incentives
to flow society's resources towards
those solutions providers
and frankly to steer money away from
companies that are a cause of problems
and are not moving us
towards a sustainable future so here's
the
the issues that i see us potentially uh
being able to step
up to um first i think there is a value
in making people pay for the harm they
cause
so the biggest green light is to have
those who are doing things in a clean
way
not polluting not pay and that's a
signal
of strong value in the business world
so again my number one green light is
price
signals and that would tell us if you're
doing things the right way you don't pay
if you're a polluter you're going to pay
for every increment of harm
you're putting out into society and this
is best done if we switch from
the 20th century approach to
environmental protection
it was largely what we in the business
call command
and control regulation uh largely around
government mandates that you can't
exceed a certain level of pollution
but everyone was allowed to pollute up
to that level for free
my argument is nothing for free anymore
either you stop your harm
no pollution in which case you don't
have to pay but if you're continuing to
pollute you're going to pay for every
increment of harm
up to the limit beyond which it's
forbidden and so that's the the core
idea of a price signal
by the way in the better planet book
bill nordhaus our prize-winning nobel
prize-winning
economist colleague lays out the case
for
price signals as the core of the
response to climate change
and i agree now more broadly
my argument is that we should really
seek to and this is the radical part of
the agenda priya promised that i'm
working on some radical ideas
um the big one is that we should really
be committed to
ending what economists would call
externalities
smoke up a smokestack effluent out of
pipeline
any kind of spillover of harm from an
industry or from an individual
onto society more broadly so i think
every company should pay for its
emissions out the smokestack
every one of us should pay for the car
exhaust out the back of our car
uh and i think it was not possible to do
this in the 20th century
because it was much too complicated to
keep track of but our information age
makes that tracking of pollution and the
pricing of harms and the passing out of
pollution bills
are really not a very difficult exercise
at all
and that again if we make people pay for
the harm they're causing
or stop what they're doing that's
causing that problem
that internalizes the externality make
sure that no one is getting
the benefit of putting harms out onto
society
for free by the way this will change
some business models
dramatically because there are some
companies that couldn't survive
except for the fact they are privatizing
the gains of their activities the
products they sell
but externalizing the costs putting at
least in part
those burdens whether in the form of
pollution or something else
onto the community onto the society more
generally
so i am arguing that we need a new
environmental protection agency
not spending its time with engineers
figuring out
what the best available technology is
and that's the core of our current law
and ordering various industries to apply
a certain smokestack scrubber or other
piece of pollution control equipment
onto their factory activity but rather
to have an epa focused on measuring harm
putting a price on it
by calculating how much risk and
epidemiological or
ecological harm is being caused and then
sending out the bills
making people pay for what they're doing
i think that kind of a structure creates
again
a big incentive to control pollution
so every factory would have a big
incentive to reduce its harm
but also to entrepreneurs and innovators
to provide
new approaches to doing all the things
we need to do that will be much lower
emissions
they will be the ones to bring to the
factories ways to cut their harm and
therefore cut their pollution bills
so i think what it does is it
incentivizes
innovation and drives people to become
solutions providers
now again as i said this connects in a
number of ways
to uh some of the other essays that are
in this book
ken gillingham my colleague in the
environment school one of the rising
star young
environmental economists also makes a
big argument around
the importance of innovation so i'm
excited that his essay lines up so
nicely
with my own uh and of course as i
mentioned bill nordhaus
uh the same thing he's making an
argument around
the importance of a policy framework
that puts a price on causing harm
and his central focus as i mentioned is
on a carbon charge
making people pay for the greenhouse gas
emissions that are contributing to
climate change
but there are a lot of other ideas that
i want to just mention
uh and i guess i i want to pause and say
that both the ken gillingham idea
and the bill nordhaus idea are aimed not
only at changing the behavior of the
polluter
but also inspiring others to help
polluters
stop polluting so it's really about not
just incentivizing more
care with the production activities of
society but also to spur
innovation and investment in
energy efficiency in uh clean energy
technology
in renewable power generation uh so
again if that is what can be done
without paying a price there will be a
relative price
signal to steer people away from fossil
fuel burning
towards these new cleaner more renewable
technologies
another source of green lights can be
information
so another part of the 21st century
sustainability strategy that i want to
sketch out
for you is how we use data
and information and the capacity to get
our hands on that information
manage it and make it actionable with
information technology
in ways that were unimaginable a couple
of decades ago
and in our better planet book are
several essays
that talk about how to do this in one
way or another one of the areas that
i've been working on
through the yale initiative on
sustainable finance which i co-direct
with
my school of management colleague todd
court is
centered on better metrics
of corporate sustainability performance
so asking companies to give us more data
on their environmental social and
governance
performance in the marketplace and that
is talked about in the investment world
by its acronym esg reporting
and right now some companies report but
the data is not very good
a lot of it's backward-looking not
forward-looking a lot of it's narrowly
focused on risk and not always focused
on who's a solutions provider therefore
upside opportunities as well as kind of
the downside burdens a company is
causing
a lot of it is very focused on
reputation rather than
operational success so there's a lot of
problems with an existing framework so
todd and i have been arguing and his
essay in the better planet book makes
clear
that we would benefit as a society from
better metrics better data on corporate
performance
really trying to understand who the
corporate sustainability leaders are
and hold them up as a place that
investors might want to go and what we
have found
is that an ever larger number of
investors
are sustainability minded they want
better alignment between their values
and where their portfolios are putting
their money so this idea of better esg
metrics
is very much what they need to make this
desire
for an alignment between their values
and their portfolio
come together so uh i think that's a
great example of where
better data investment and information
and in this case specifically
in a next generation of esg
metrics is going to be essential
now of course some of it still will be
risk oriented
and from a climate change point of view
knowing which companies
are as we now say carbon exposed
likely to be suffering more consequences
than their competitors or those
companies that are in other industries
will be of real value and in particular
companies holding fossil fuel assets may
find themselves
with what are known as stranded assets
oil in the ground
natural gas underground that can't ever
be taken advantage of
because it has become disfavored as we
move to a clean energy future
but the next generation of metrics that
i want to see
goes even beyond those kind of core
elements the things like
which companies and which industries and
which management teams of those
companies
are positioned to transition to a
decarbonized future
because that's what people would really
like to know in the marketplace
looking out ahead 10 or 15 or 20 years
who's positioned
to be a success in business and whose
business model may
fail because it's trapped in the
fossil fuel past now i think that whole
idea
of a different approach for business of
really trying to
understand who the leaders are from a
sustainability perspective
dovetails with another of the essays
that i very much like
uh the one by carter roberts who's the
head of the world wildlife fund
and he has written about kind of the
need for a new business
business ethos and that actually is
capturing a spirit of the moment
suddenly there's a lot of talk that the
old business
mission of thinking that the goal is
always to maximize profits
or to deliver what the famous university
of chicago economist once called
shareholder primacy is giving way
to a new business spirit that focuses on
stakeholder responsibility
and that means that a business is not
just delivering goods
uh and profits for its shareholders its
owners
but has some responsibility to its
employees to the communities it operates
in to its customers to its suppliers
and i think uh that argument very much
is what carter roberts
is uh saying in his essay in this better
planet book
i believe that there is a societal value
change
underway that is basically saying to the
business community
you need to be more broad-minded it
can't simply be
all about profits and certainly not
about profits
where you are privatizing gains and
socializing putting on all of us the
costs of things like your pollution
so better information makes that
possible we've got a new capacity with
data
and information technology to track
who's putting those emissions out
and again in my reimagined world making
those people pay for the harms they're
causing
now it is also the case that with better
data
and tracking we can manage a whole set
of other
sustainability or environmental problems
better and another of the essays that in
the better planet book i find really
inspiring in its uh
nod to where the future might go is the
one by my environment school colleague
marion certo
on waste management and marian some of
you may know has been in that arena
for something like 30 years uh and has
really been
on the front lines of thinking about how
we do recapture and recycling of
materials
and how we try to minimize waste uh and
that's a
booming issue of societal concern uh
obviously around things like plastic but
even more broadly
and so marion lays out with one of her
uh students
a beautiful argument for a price-based
strategy of waste management where you
make people pay for what they throw away
but allow them to recycle for free and
uh
she's got a a well-structured essay
on how it is we might reimagine waste
management to really ensure that we get
to a more
closed-loop use of materials where that
which can be taken back
recaptured and reused will be and where
we're minimizing that which goes out
uh forever as waste likewise there's a
great essay in the book from tracy
meehan
uh and by the way one of the notable
things about this book is
these are not essays from
environmentalists they're from
environmental analysts
so people who are really expert in their
fields
and it seeks very much to have
perspectives that are not
all on the left side of the political
spectrum but include a number of
republicans
one of whom is tracy meehan and has
written an excellent essay on water
management
basically making the argument we can't
afford to have such a thing as
waste water we need to be able to
recapture clean and reuse
all of our water supplies absolutely
correct
this is true in general even more true
in a world where climate change is going
to stress
uh traditional water flows uh
traditional
rainfall patterns and of course we're
seeing even in connecticut this year
the emergence of a serious drought so a
great essay on
water as a scarce resource needing to
have a price on it to incentivize
care and conservation in its management
and to encourage
investments in the sort of
infrastructure that allows us to be much
more
tight in our water systems not lose
water
now it also is the case that we
recognize
that some of the problems of the past
are a function of people not
thinking about uh ecological linkages
and ah schmitz has a great essay
on the need to understand ecosystems in
a more holistic way
understand the connections across
different aspects of the plant and
animal world
and i think this provides a very
important science foundation
for this uh 21st century approach to
environmental protection i'm imagining
and just adjacent to that argument that
ah schmitz presents
uh is another essay from uh authors that
uh
have their homes in the school of the
environment paul anastas and julie
zimmerman
who make the case for a systems
perspective
in environmental law and policy an
integrated approach
not a siloed approach arguing that the
20th century was often about
managing air and water and waste and
land in
separate legal structures and separate
incentive frameworks
and it hasn't worked out that well we've
misunderstood
the connections and in some cases just
move pollution from one form to another
most famously if you put a scrubber on a
smoke stack and it pulls the suit out of
the stack
now you have a solid waste and you put
it in the land now you have a land waste
and then when rain water comes through
it it takes it into a stream and now
you've turned it into a water
problem so that's not a very good
approach and that's the kind of thing
that
paula nastus and julie zimmerman are
calling out with their essay aimed at
systems thinking systems design and
really a much more holistic approach to
how we produce things
what kinds of products we produce and
our framework of of law and policy
in response similarly jane lubchenko
who's written a beautiful essay on
oceans
tells us that we need to get beyond our
past framework that the ocean was too
big and it wouldn't ever be polluted by
us could we couldn't affect it because
it was so vast
to the more recent view that the ocean
is doomed that it's full of plastic and
hopeless
to her argument that the ocean is
central
fundamental to life on earth and is
too big not to fix so that is i think
a beautiful perspective but her
secondary argument
is that we have to understand that we
have people in our ecosystems people
affect the ocean and we needed to manage
the ocean
and the people that live on the planet
in a more integrated way
understanding trade-offs and recognizing
the need for the
ocean to work as an ecosystem but also
for people
and again it's a systems perspective
played out in one particular
venue a fabulous essay from subinaz who
was for many years
on the state department's climate change
team the lead environmental lawyer in
the state department
she has a similar argument when it comes
to climate change
that you can't rely on the paris climate
change agreement of 2015
to do all the work we need to do we've
got to bring others
whose behavior whose incentive structure
shapes choices that determine whether we
have a lot of greenhouse gases or not
so she would argue in the international
domain yes we have a
framework convention on climate change
with a staff that works on it
but we need to pull in the world trade
organization and the world bank
in the international labor organization
all to be part of a unified effort
to respond to the sustainability
challenge broadly
to climate change in particular another
area where i think we've got
work to do is on investment as i
mentioned
one of the critical shortfalls of the
20th century
was not paying attention where the money
would come from to create
a sustainable future to invest in the
infrastructure
that we would need clean energy
infrastructure and more
larry seltzer who runs the the
conservation fund
a another environmental group makes a
very interesting argument
that if we are going to get land
conservation done at the scale we need
and tom lovejoy and yet another essay
tells us that biodiversity requires us
to be
much more protective of a much wider
swath of land
well larry seltzer's piece of the story
is to say governments will never do
enough
we need to make sure that there is
private capital being deployed
to be part of our land conservation
effort and he talks about
land trusts and other ways of bringing
private funds
into our land conservation agenda
and really effectively a new model for
how we're going to do
the scale of habitat protection required
for
a thriving human population as well as
plant and animal
life another of the
essays that i think is really
interesting or several of the essays
relate to the need for new approaches to
communications
uh tony lacerowicz in particular from
our yale
uh community climate change
communications project
lays out a very interesting set of views
about
how americans see the problem of climate
change what motivates them to take
action
even what words resonate with people and
i think
understanding how to communicate science
to the policy arena is again a terrible
breakdown of the past and something we
need to get much better about
going forward into the future and that
brings me to one
final essay that i just want to mention
and uh
in a book with 40 essays that i'm the
editor of
i'm not allowed to have a favorite just
as no parent can have a favorite child
but i do want to say the essay by thomas
easley has resonated in a very big and
broad way
his piece is called hip-hop
sustainability
and it reflects his reality of being a
dean in the school of the environment
but also as a hip-hop artist and the
case he makes
is for bringing the discussion around
sustainability
and including climate change in
particular the communities that have
been left out of the conversation
in his case uh the black community the
inner city community
the world that he talks to in his hip
hop music and his argument is that if
you can speak to people in their
own terms in their own way of
approaching a problem
they're much more likely to engage and
he is of course
correct so his ability to broaden the
discussion bring people into
a political dialogue that they didn't
know they had an important reason to be
part of
is i think quite stunning so let me
close just by saying
uh a few more visions of the 21st
century strategy
for a sustainable future that the better
planet book
lays out uh we had a very top-down
approach to policy in the 20th century
we need to have some top-down uh
priorities and targets set
but with bottom-up implementation
recognizing not all the work will be
done by the federal government
some will be done at the state level
some at the local level and oh by the
way some will be done at the global
level
over it all we do have the opportunity
to build on information technologies
that weren't available
in the past century we do have enormous
potential
to bring data and data tracking
technologies to bear
to give us new tools and new
possibilities for how to limit harm
particularly the idea of tracing and
tracking
emissions and putting a price on those
and frankly i would argue that the
environmental arena is
curiously unaffected up till now
by the entire revolution of information
technology
no other arena of society that i'm aware
of
has done so little to bring information
technology to bear
you know no baseball team today picks
players the way they might have
uh 30 years ago when a scout would be
chewing tobacco and saying well that guy
has good stuff
and this guy doesn't no they're data
driven they now measure
how hard people hit how fast they run
how quickly they jump
um so it's a data driven world and that
same spirit
just hasn't been deeply embedded into
the environmental world
yet but there is a potential to do it
now
as i said we're going to need to move
away from government mandates as the
core of our regulatory framework
the government pricing of harms letting
people be flexible in what they choose
to do about that
but pay fully for every bit of harm
they're causing
and again a more integrated world where
we're thinking in a
unified way an ecological way about
problems
recognizing connections and trade-offs
and trying to be more coherent in how we
manage that
and uh as i said it's a world that needs
more innovation
uh to get to a much cleaner future we
can't rely on the tools of the past the
frameworks of the past
uh the incentives the past we need to
move forward
and i do think that the core of the
argument
should be this new value foundational
value
that takes the right of breathers ever
more seriously
so i don't think it's the case that
society doesn't care who has
the underlying environmental rights i
think we need to lodge with all of us
the right to a clean environment uh to
make environmental justice
a more central part of our policy
framework and
with that i would argue we have a new
principle that commits to an
end of externalities every polluter
either stops their harm causing
or pays fully so that's a lot to lay on
the table
i invite now questions and comments i'm
often asked whether i see
uh a promising path whether i'm an
optimist
or whether i think all the the the
shower of bad news
uh makes me a pessimist and my answer is
i am somewhat pessimistic in the short
term but in the long term i think
there's lots of opportunities and as
this book demonstrates
lots of paths forward so with that let
me stop and invite your questions your
comments your pushback
and let's have a dialogue
thank you so much dan for this wonderful
talk
and please feel free to start uh
typing up um your questions in the chat
uh tai has kindly offered to moderate
and help us handle the questions
and if i may use my provocative as the
organizer to ask the first question
um so dan i i see that you are
optimistic at the policy level
in terms of the interventions that can
be done
and that will be very very effective i
was just wondering
whether you are optimistic in terms of
the
at the individual level because you know
we are seeing a rampant
uh denialism of science of climate
change
so how do we change people's minds
about being more open and sort of
accepting of the facts that are
unrolling in front of our eyes
so yeah and the connected question is do
you see
you know young activists like greta
tinberg
actually playing an important role going
forward
um how do you see the sort of the
activism
side of that movement as well
thank you um so priya you've raised one
of the most
depressing uh and could be
pessimism-inducing
aspects of our current moment which is
how many people seem uninterested
in science in data in rational analysis
um in having policy grounded in
facts uh and empirical analysis so it
really
uh it could be a source of enormous
distress
and i am actually distressed by that i
think however that the lesson
of our covid19 moment may well be that
if you don't pay attention to all of
that
you suffer and it's not that somebody
else suffers you will suffer your family
will suffer
um and there are kind of straightforward
ways to put your risk into a much lower
category by wearing a mask and
social distancing um and the people who
are doing that
are having a better outcome than people
or not and of course there's bad luck
people that work behaving properly that
still get the disease and
risky behavior folks who don't but over
the broad
scope of society i think it's going to
appear very clear
that the people who are following
science following data
are going to come out better but i am
stunned
at our current political moment where so
many people still
even if they have faced personal
challenges don't seem to
act in their public life in their
political life
with regard to that very straightforward
logic
so i think it is uh worrisome
i do think that we have activists who
are starting to sharpen our thinking
um and greta gets great credit for
having raised the profile of climate
change
uh her school strikes i think have
motivated lots of young people to think
this can't be left to the folks who are
of my generation your generation
to solve the problem we haven't yet
gotten there and
the the young folks i think are willing
to be more creative to try
new things um but i i do think and i
i don't know whether this is put on
greta specifically but i do think
there is also um some challenges for the
young
and i see this um you know in uh in many
contexts
but there are trade-offs one of the
reasons we still have a pandemic debate
on
is because it is a terrible thing that
people have lost their jobs
so there is an economic counterpoint
to the pandemic that is real and people
have suffered
really serious life losses because of
lost jobs lost economic
security so i think the fact is that
those who care about the environment
have to acknowledge
that most people also care about their
families economic security
uh the ability to have a job so how do
you balance
jobs in the environment uh has got to be
taken more seriously
and in that regard you know i pray i'm
going to end with your question
because i think it's the right one i i
think the answer is data and science and
good analysis that's how
how you do balancing that's how you make
trade-offs um
and i don't see any other path forward
but to dig deeper
into the science and have it emerge even
more fully and forcefully
as the foundation for our decision
making
thank you very much i think for mrs
frankie
well thank you uh to follow up with
thomas
easley's thoughts incidentally
his last name and mine are the same my
maiden name was
easily so um
has any work been done to
help with education as far as
primary and secondary schools are
concerned i
i know it is an area where our hope may
be
if they are educated along the lines
that you're proposing
so i would tell you that um almost
everyone who's thought
long and hard about what it's going to
take to get to a sustainable future
sees education and frankly in
generational
shifts in underlying understanding and
values
as foundational and i think this is true
in some arenas that we know already and
can see the evidence
you know the the world of recycling
didn't exist when you and i were young
um we had to be retrained and we're
still not always probably as good as the
younger folks i have to admit to
occasionally throwing
a a beer can in the trash and not in the
recycling bin
now my children just think that's absurd
they they would never imagine
throwing away a good aluminum can that's
ready for uh
repurposing as a new aluminum can so
that's an element of
retraining and of education where the
young have got it
clear in their minds they don't even
have to think about it where some of us
are still slow on the draw so i do think
better environmental education being
beginning at the earliest grades
deepening the understanding of science
is the foundation
is going to be quite fundamental to
success on all of this
dan a question from the chat uh we have
a couple of piled up
uh someone says thanks for raising the
issue of incorporating externalities in
our economic analyses
how do you suggest that might occur
so i think there are several ways to do
this again i'm a big believer in
bringing a much richer base of data and
analytics
to environmental policy so i would like
to have people report
more fully uh on their environmental
impacts i think we should require
companies
to provide metrics that tell us how much
in the way of greenhouse gases they're
emitting what kind of harm they're
putting out their effluent pipe into the
the rivers and streams nearby what
they're putting up a smokestack beyond
greenhouse gases
that uh might be of societal concern and
uh
with that data one can begin to put a
number on it that's why i'm saying we
need to
recast our epa away from the engineers
of the past
and toward epidemiologists ecologists
risk analysts
and economists who will do that work
of putting a number on the externalities
and then sending out the bills
making people pay for the harm they're
causing and by the way some people think
that sounds
quite radical it's actually not uh
this has been the core of environmental
efforts over
400 years which basically said going
back to some of the earliest uh
nuisance cases uh in british law
400 years ago on which american law
builds the the most famous case is uh
called
aldrid and in that case a pig farmer was
told you can't have your smelly pigs
polluting the neighborhood stinking up
the neighborhood either get rid of your
pigs stop the harm
or you're gonna have to pay your
neighbors for the harm you're causing so
this idea
of ending externalities making people
pay for their harm
is 400 years old in our anglo-american
legal tradition
many companies are producing esg goals
spontaneously
from within the organization but u.s
fossil fuel companies are singularly
refractory to such endeavors
how can they be brought around so i
actually am um not very optimistic
about voluntary environmental social
governance reporting
i think there's a problem never mind in
the fossil fuel industry but broadly
that companies tend to report uh on
their own terms and without regard to
the need for comparability
across the data one company to the next
so i'm in favor
of uh having our securities and exchange
commission
uh establish a core set of
sustainability metrics again in the
environment social and governance
categories that would be required
along alongside of financial data as
part of quarterly and annually corporate
reports
as providing the foundational
information that the stock market needs
so that people can understand
uh who's in a good position who's not um
and frankly it should gauge
those who are providing solutions to the
market so that we can say that's a
company that may be a a winner over time
as well as those who are causing harms
or holding assets that are um
that are a problem uh holding fossil
fuel assets for example
so i do think a a framework
a government structure of um
sustainability metrics is probably the
way to go
and that would of course apply first and
foremost to the fossil fuel companies
that would then have to tell us uh what
their risks are
uh and whether they're counting on
getting at all these fossil fuels they
hold
for their future success thank you
another
question there are some consequences to
removing fossil fuels
the lwcf just got full funding in the
great american outdoors act
but it is funded by royalties from oil
and gas exploration in the north sea
won't they have less money to pay their
royalties going forward
um yes and in fact that might be an
argument in
uh some might push back on my entire pay
for your externalities uh
line of reasoning because the goal over
time is actually not to have people pay
it's to have people stop polluting um
and likewise
uh to the extent that royalties from
fossil fuel exploitation
uh are what fund that um land and water
account uh we probably over time have to
plan for a day when those numbers begin
to dwindle
because the amount of fossil fuels being
extracted is going dramatically down
okay um please could you explain more
about the metrics that companies need to
have to achieve
sdg for example b lab provides some
tools
but maybe there are more that can be
built in the near future
so this raises another very good point
and let me just back up in case not
everyone's familiar with the sdg
reference but in addition in 2015 to
having the paris climate
change agreement the u.n put forward
something called the sustainable
development goals
17 different goals that represent really
not just
challenges of environment but many other
issues including ending poverty ending
hunger
moving towards clean energy providing
better public health
all of which are underpinned by metrics
so there's 169
targets that have been set that these
goals are meant to drive countries
towards addressing
over the 15 years to 2030. so i do think
there's a lot of work being done on
measuring sustainable development goals
and a good number of companies i would
say many companies that are serious
about their sustainability strategies
are trying to translate some of those
goals
into their own corporate reporting
framework so they're putting together
uh a corporate report on some of the
goals that they think are most relevant
to their own business their own industry
and putting that information out to the
world uh it may well be that
as part of the the government mandated
esg disclosure esg reporting that i
would like to see
that a a core set of those sustainable
development goals would be among the
things required
okay thank you um
comments here the call for bottom up or
top down
is still too anthropocentric this is a
recipe for collapse one of our
participants
suggests we need to transcend this
vocabulary and these metaphors
uh he followed up a bit later with this
more data and
greater amounts of science are not
enough we need to change the fundamental
metaphors our culture
is working with and uh he mentions
the fatal consequences of a misplaced
metaphor in the agricultural industry
so um first of all i do think how you
frame things matters
and again several of the essays in the
better planet book make that point
jade levchenko's uh essay on the oceans
is all about a new narrative for the
oceans
um tony elizarowitz's work on climate
change is all about
how you frame the issue in a manner that
engages more people and brings them into
the conversation
uh gets them to take the issue more
seriously um i think the chain
the challenge that the questioner is
presenting is that
it's very very difficult to uh deliver
such a radical change of perspectives
that people are going beyond their own
human interest to really uh focus as
much as maybe we should
would like them to on uh biodiversity on
the
on the world of nature as an equally
important priority
and you know my own experience in the
policy arena is that it's in fact a
failing cause to try to hope that
everyone's going to be high-minded
and take nature as seriously as human
life so instead i believe
that the best hope is to frame the
agenda around how nature supports people
and that we need to protect biodiversity
and uh support the ocean
uh because in part at least it is
essential for our own human success
thank you please could you elaborate
more about environmental justice
especially because nowadays there is an
increased role of climate litigation
in advancing and undermining climate
change action
so i do think uh at the core of my uh
vision for a 21st century
approach to environmental protection is
this idea
of not permitting any externalities that
is to say at least no pollution for
free uh there may be some unavoidable
level of uh
of harm that's going to be emitted but
it should all be fully paid for
at uh at rates that will provide ongoing
deterrence and encourage people to
continue to
move away from harm causing and i do
think more broadly
that uh what is now often talked about
is climate justice beyond environmental
justice
is suggesting that uh it's unfair to a
number of communities to have uh
the risk of climate change rising and i
like to say that climate change is
particularly challenging
because the the vectors of
responsibility are even more complicated
than with most issues
which is to say greenhouse gas emissions
blanket the earth
so there is a geographic spread of
enormous scale
no one country can solve the problem
alone even if the united states uh
entirely counterfactually were to stop
all emissions tomorrow
it would only take 15 percent of the
emissions at the global scale
out of the system we'd still have 85
remaining so it can only be addressed in
a collective
global approach and furthermore from a
point of view of climate justice
there's not only a spatial spread that's
enormous but
across time a temporal spread and
a lot of the harm that's being done is
to none not anyone who's alive today but
our children our grandchildren and their
children and grandchildren
so there is a profound intergenerational
equity dimension here as well
so i do think environmental justice is a
big topic
along several different lines including
a more immediate harm spilled from
factories onto adjacent communities
often communities that are disadvantaged
communities of color
and then these various vectors of
justice
related to the climate change problem so
lots to work through
and much of it's been under attended to
uh in the past
kind of uh environmental discussions and
empire and environmental policy
frameworks that have been in place
okay i hope i'm not missing the
beginning part of this question
uh wouldn't this additional layer of
sustainability metrics result in another
level of corporate government
governance and middle management
no i think um the requirement that
companies report on the environment is
something that most
companies of any scale are doing already
they're just not doing it in a coherent
cross-company cross-industry comparable
way
so i think it could in fact be
simplifying
for companies to have a single reporting
framework
defined by the government right now
there's a dozen different private sector
uh groups out there in the data
analytics world trying to collect this
data
sending out surveys uh pushing companies
to respond to their
uh survey and and as a result there's a
a scramble within companies to keep up
with all these requests
so a single unified government structure
would i think actually
cut the amount of time and effort
required and improve the quality and
comparability of the data
in a way that would benefit maybe not
every company but certainly all the
investors
who want that framework of comparable
high quality high integrity data
that they can actually trust and would
view as a foundation
for making investment decisions
okay uh continued comment from other one
of the participants
we now need to move beyond the major
universities and change public discourse
in
culture other rhodes scholars have been
working on this for a while
and he suggests uh i guess you're
familiar with them
so what is the question there uh i guess
just the comment about moving beyond the
major universities and changing public
discourse
maybe more just of a common um you know
i think there is um
uh obviously a case to have uh the the
conversation carried beyond universities
to be taken into the public domain into
the political arena
i think again as i mentioned earlier
what's notable about this year's
presidential election
is the degree to which environment
broadly but climate change in particular
has been part of the debate much more so
in the past
and i do think again we can credit some
of the younger
activists for having driven the agenda
uh and for having ensured that the
candidates really in both parties
um are having to step up and answer
questions
and i think that's given the public as
clear a
signal and has sharply defined a choice
on that set of issues as we have seen in
in any recent election
thank you i think we've covered the
questions that have been submitted thus
far
i'm just checking for any new ones but i
think
that's pretty much it good well it's
been a pleasure to be part of this
conversation um
i thank priya and the entire team at the
frankie center for uh
the opportunity to be uh with you today
and to have this discussion
and uh hope some of you will carry it
forward in your own way and in your own
uh
settings uh in the weeks and months
ahead
thank you so much dan for speaking and
for an
absolutely wonderful talk well it's a
pleasure
and uh i wish you all well as you think
about how to advance the sustainability
agenda from your own starting points